well let's get labour's view on this now
shall we i'm joined by the shadow
business secretary jonathan reynolds a
very good morning
so the economy contracting in in the
second quarter we had that news this
morning meanwhile we're warned that
energy bills could go up as high as 5
000 pounds
next year so what exactly is labour's
plan of how it would be tackled well
good morning yes i mean unfortunately it
seems there's a crisis in every aspect
of national life under this government
at the moment but there's no doubt that
the energy emergency is the most
significant and pressing one facing
households and businesses now we've been
setting out since january of this year
that plan for a windfall tax of using
that revenue to support households there
is already a win
well it doesn't it begins actually we
would go back to january when we made
that case when you started to see that
windfall occurring so we have more
revenue that we could put into the
system but obviously as the crisis has
only got worse since we began making the
case for that clearly further action is
required now we're going to be sending
that out over the weeks and days ahead
but i can tell you today that part of
that response will be for instance we
will end uh the immoral practice of
people who pay for their energy in
advance through a prepayment meter
that's about four million households in
the uk being charged more than people
who pay by direct debits so we would
stop there being a higher cap for those
pre-payment customers we'd give them the
relief now we'd be able to reimburse
energy suppliers for the cost of that
running into march next year because we
can raise more revenue through the
windfall tax to clear targeted tax that
we put forward but we're going to
continue to do this there is no doubt we
don't need any more information about
the scale of the crisis we get it we
understand it we're going to be making
the case for that well if you get it and
you understand it why are we just
getting an announcement on pre-payment
today i mean we've had lots of ideas
from the liberal democrats had lots of
ideas from gordon brown as well so why
isn't labour telling us exactly what the
plan is well i would say we go back to
january of this year when we started no
but you don't have a clear plan
now we do have a very clear plan now
what we what we're saying today is we
recognize this crisis has only got worse
and we're going to continue with our
response to match the the scale of that
now why the windfall tax argument from
us i think was successful was because
not only we were calling for action but
we had a very clear plan as to how we'd
spend the revenue of that where help
would go to what people could expect so
we're going to make sure we have the
detail of that and we have that for next
week but we're making the case that we
get the scale of the crisis we've been
calling for action since january but
we're going to continue to do so and
each time we're going to make sure
people recognize the specific measures
that would benefit them and in this case
today's those prepayment customers four
million households who get extra support
okay so we have to wait for more details
but what about general theories let's
ask you about what you made of what
gordon brown has said this week he
talked about uh for energy companies
that don't
offer lower bills aren't able to charge
people less that they should be
temporarily re-nationalized now is that
a good idea well i very much welcome
what gordon brown said this week because
he's recognizing the scale of the crisis
i also welcome by the way as a reminder
that we have had in the past prime
ministers labor prime ministers who can
deal with the crisis in this case the
global financial crisis and respond to
that now i would just say on the case
that gordon made he was right to say
that the state has to act as the supply
of last resort to make sure people can
get gas and electric if their supplier
goes out or business that's already
broadly the case in terms of how the
system works but where we need specific
action is in you you can take supply
companies into public ownership but
that's not going to solve the problem
the windfall is accruing on the
production side and therefore that's
right the windfall tax is the right
intervention to take a share of that
windfall for the benefit of the economy
as a whole and that's the right thing to
do so i think it's very important we
understand we get across to people
that's the action that is required in
itself bringing a public company into
public control isn't a response to the
crisis but he's right to say the state
has to guarantee the supply then okay
but let me be clear is labor against
nationalization well it's not part of
our response to the cost of living
because what is required there is direct
financial support for people which we
would raise through a windfall tax it's
just important to say obviously that if
you look at where the country has has
been coming through the pandemic
borrowing a lot of money that was
absolutely the right thing to do but
over time the share of debt to the size
of the economy does have to shrink and
there are limitations that come from the
fact that you've had to increase public
borrowing in response to the pandemic
you said you welcomed an intervention
from the likes of gordon brown who you
say is greatly respected so let's take a
look at something else that he said
yesterday time and tide wait for no one
he said neither do crises they don't
take holidays and don't politely hang
fire was that a dig at sakisama who's
been on holiday no not at all i think
that was not about i think what gordon
brown is pointing out is we have this
incredible crisis the scale of which has
real consequences for people and we have
no effective functioning government i
mean there is simply no response to that
akira is actually in scotland today he's
doing some media doing some live
interviews around a few things including
the response to this no i don't think
that was a dig at all i think what
gordon was right to say in the past and
he's a good example of this we've seen
governments labor governments respond to
challenges that are very significant why
can't we have a response from this
government to this crisis but kirsten
wasn't around this week there is no plan
forthcoming yet so having a dig at the
government would be missing an action
it's not right to say there's no plan
yet i mean go back we haven't got the
full well the windfall tax plans we're
moving vat off energy bills it's
removing some of the levees that appear
on people's bills and changing how they
are paid for massively increasing the
scope of warmth homes discount in terms
of the value of that to people and who
is eligible for that so about a third of
british households would get that going
further today by saying people who use
prepayment meters won't have that
additional cost and we're going to
continue do so so i think we are putting
forward that plan but the fact is every
day the crisis is getting worse so the
response has to grow to that okay so uh
more detail to come all right jonathan
reynolds thanks very much thank you